ce serait incroyable brandon j'espère
que vous avez maintenant entre vos mains
la boîte à 1000 euros et qu'on avait
changés 1000 euros contre 100 mille
euros marie-jeanne soit du bluff soir
c'est peut-être ça l'histoire refais toi
l'histoire du banquier c'est vrai parce
que à un moment il a fait et a proposé
20 milles ça proposé 15 mhz et a proposé
20 milles est-ce qu'il n'avait pas peur
de ce que tu avais dans ta boîte ou bien
est ce qu'ils se disaient c'est son
chiffre fétiche religion et que tu fais
n'avons reçu d'offre du monde antony tu
refuses d'échangés taboye tu refuses les
changes du banquier peut-être que le
banquier là il a fait tout ça pour
traduire en erreur et peut-être qu'en
fait avec 500 euros ici que depuis le d
une sig des joueurs et qui se dit
anthony il va tomber les deux pieds
dedans dans mon piège tu viens de
prendre la décision de ne pas échanger
ta boite on donne ce soir on aura pas
d'événements historiques
mon chéri brandon si brandon à les 30000
euros dans sa boite ça veut dire
qu'anthony il aura refusé 20000 euros
pour repartir avec 500 euros ça sera une
déconvenue
je vous dis moi je vais être au bout de
ma vie et vous aussi tous parce qu'on
adore anthony les 21h29 brandon
notre général allez ça parce qu'on va
faire la sourde au sort nous les 500
euros
vous allez montre notre alimentation
fallait pour l'aller
je le sens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et d'une heure 22 on est en direct
exact était bon choix s kalex a bien
fait de ne pas échanger sa boîte depuis
le début isabelle pouvait rester la même
chose merci à
alex jouer est ce que dans votre boîte
fétiche avec 15000 euros les 500 euros
votre boîte fétiche et l'a9
il avait choisi de garder la 24 jusqu'au
bout alex on veut voir dans la boîte
adrien et que j'ai vu
est ce que j'ai vu 500 euros 15000 euros
on aimerait que ce soir 500 euros dans
la boîte adrien adrien
[Musique]
on alex il a joué avec vos nerfs le
banquier les 15000 euros hésité dans la
9 et dans la 24 il y avait 500 euros
plusieurs fois on a failli changer la
boîte
alexandre êtes un type exceptionnel que
j'adore il savait bien ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec la caisse comprend
l'arabe santé doit on la prend 1,25 et
borat ou beaucoup trop divisés par deux
os x 2 ou bien plus 1000 euros je veux
même pas voir je n'aime pas voir avant
il a chéri
me l'apprenez
c'est une banqueroute
[Musique]
vraiment c'est pas grave c'est la
première fois que ça arrive un come back
dans l'émission c'est encore un nouveau
scénario ce soir qu'on vous propose
c'est fou on va ouvrir la boîte 22,6
dans la 22e il ya les 50 centimes d'euro
parce que là vous avez plus rien ans et
plus les 3500 euros c'est à nu mais vous
comprenez chez vous c'est tout annuler
n'est plus les 3500 euros vous acceptez
le come back
ça veut dire que c'est où vous partez
avec 50 centimes d'euro vont partait que
5000 euros la boîte 22 c'était la boîte
de miss france il axe qui l'a sans plus
trop
on espère qu'elle a raison de plus trop
la sentir on espère qu'elle 50 centimes
d'euro dans la boîte de tiffany notre
voyageuse l'a22 allez allez allez
c'est la loi croyable encore ce soir
mais je les aime trop qu'il s'était
juste les mails et les étoiles il était
toujours là pour nous ils sont généreux
ils sont gentils ils ont été tellement
bien élever sa robe c'est vraiment de
personnes en or j'espère tellement
tellement tellement tellement qui a du
rouge dans my back aller kiffan il nous
faut les 50 centimes d'euro dans votre
boîte dont le come back on accepter
comme baky
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on espère que dans sept mois de 18
il ya les 500 euros vous avez fait une
partie remarquable vous aviez la boîte
13 vous l'avez échangé contre la boîte
une dans la boîte 13 il y avait 50 euros
heureusement qu'on s'en débarrasser
j'espère que notre johnny le smile qu'on
aime va nous porter chance
[Musique]
il
linda
[Musique]
dell à partir ce soir ou avec 500 euros
avec 10000 euros on est de refuser 4500
euros
s'il ya 500 euros dans la boîte de
johnny ça veut dire que vous avez des
10000 euros
s'il ya 10000 euros ça veut dire nous on
va partir et ce soir avec 500 euros
donnés quand vous voulez
[Musique]
nda vous repartez avec 500 euros ce soir
alors il ya la 25e boîte ouvrez votre
boîte linda y avait la 25e boîte on fait
quoi / 2 x de banqueroute ou plus 1000
euros on fait quoi on l'a se rend on
l'attend allez on espère qui a multiplié
par deux opus 1000 euros ce serait le
mieux linda c'est linda vous repartez
avec zéro euro désolé lui là j'aurai
pour la police très très fort nous a
fait
[Musique]
c'est quitte ou double heureusement
m
forcément une forte
le temps
c'est le moment pardon je dis des gros
coups c'est mon regret de chez nous
c'est horrible mais c'est atroce c'est
marie jawad est ce que vous avez fait le
bon choix
est ce que vous venez d'échangés 1000
euros contre 100 mille euros
ouais ce qu'aurait d'échangés cent mille
euros contre 1000 euros
[Musique]
tout cas marc et jardins en italie ça
porte malheur le 17 mai j'espère que ça
portera chance ce soir on donne il est
19 heures 39
on veut des bonnes nouvelles pour marie
jeanne j'espère que vous avez fait le
bon choix marie jade que vous allez plus
mais le banquier que vous allez repartir
avec 100000 euros ce soir ce serait
incroyable brandon j'espère que vous
avez maintenant entre vos mains la boîte
à 1000 euros et qu'on avait changés 1000
euros contre 100 mille euros mary jane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans vider